okay next question today David would you
and do you want to debate Dave Rubin
okay so I mean let's let's break this
down into its component pieces would I
debate Dave Rubin I sure I would do I
want to debate Dave Dave Rubin I don't
have a particular drive or desire to
debate Dave Rubin but I would love to
have another conversation with him like
we did an hour or so conversation like
like the last time or we can actually go
through his views and beliefs and and
all of that stuff now the thing about do
you willyou debate x person i get a lot
of this on twitter like will you debate
candice Owens will you debate charlie
Kirk or ben shapiro it depends on the
topic right it can't be just a
conversation there needs to be some kind
of purpose to the conversation and I
think that sometimes what people miss
when they simply say there should be a
debate I was once asked I don't remember
who it was that came to me might have
been the drunken peasants in a prior
iteration who said hey we want you to
debate sargon of akkad this guy Karl
Benjamin but he goes by Sargon of Akkad
and I said okay well what's the topic
and they said brexit I'm not an expert
on brexit I don't feel super strongly on
brexit where I would be the person
representing any particular point of
view on that and and so I said that's
not really a good topic for me let's
debate healthcare policy let's debate
tax policy let's debate media bias let's
debate you know a whole litany of other
topics but I don't find that debate for
the sake of debate sort of like the
internet blood sports mentality is that
productive or good for anybody so I
would be glad to have a conversation
with Dave Rubin anytime he wants he's
welcome on my program I've offered to go
on his program and at one point it
seemed like maybe it was going to happen
but then he had Tucker Carlson on
instead last time I was in LA which is
fine Tucker Carlson's a way bigger name
than I am and I totally get that as far
as a debate I would be would be glad to
have a debate with him if it's a topic
that makes sense for me and the same
exact thing applies to Candice Owens or
Charlie
Herick or whoever else